[Music]
this is a rarity
Casey's always up before me you're
snooping in for the first time ever this
is like so rare I don't know what you
said but I gotta go anymore I am gonna
cut my hair this hair is being chopped
off enjoy it cuz it's gonna be gone let
me smell it
we're so beard yeah take a bite of this
stuff I like this look your chest is
nice
look of tip yeah so I'm heading over to
your ease cuz she is chopping this all
up I'm gonna be having a bob and then
I'm gonna go blonde and but that's next
week but this week I am chopping it off
and I'm so excited because when I got
blue hair I was telling her that I
really wanted a bob like I want it
floating above my shoulders but then I
assumed she must have thought that I was
not serious and not fully committing to
the Bob so she ended up cutting it like
right out where my shoulders I was kind
of bummed out then I was like I wanted
it shorter but I was like it's okay it's
fine so then now it's grown out all this
down here is really damaged so I'm glad
that's gonna get chopped off they're
actually running late like always I
gotta go ever I love you I love you
check out these cute socks I got by the
way we're not give them to me for
Christmas
they're so cute they're little ears and
stuff okay I'm really distracted I gotta
go you let me get me
[Music]
it's happening it's happening we're
gonna call it off right here shorter
here shorter no way
yeah like right there right here yeah
okay great right above your shoulders
high a little higher it'll buff your
show yeah I want it like floating okay
okay
I am so excited for this
Oh lighter okay we're gonna finish this
[Music]
oh who is this sexy mama and look it up
fill in this yeah I'm so feeling this
you are so yeah thank the girl love it I
really love it I got so much I really
like it I feel so fierce you're like
like you're ready got this oh my gosh
it's so short what do you think yeah
she's doing my color next week I'm gonna
start being blonde I'm gonna be a blonde
years I love it so good I love it so
much thank you mom looks okay
I wonder what keeps I'm gonna say oh I
even like smelled my hair and you kissed
it oh my god
all right I'm home now let's see Casey's
reaction I'm excited
I wonder he's gonna say honey I'm home
I can't feel like cardi B right now no
sir so he goes like short hair I love it
person she was cutting it and then I was
looking in the mirror I'm like you feel
so hot I like it
you like hi I'm filling this haircut
yeah and then watch me when I'm blonde
oh we only have one week of you have
brown hair brown sugar one week enjoy it
last feel so free like when does it feel
lighter like you can like do stuff yes
it does feel lighter heavy that's sure
is this the first time you've ever had
short hair like this
I think this short yeah I don't think
I've ever had it this short guys what do
you guys think you have that kind of
look and body and like just proportion
that anything like fit looks good on you
you're just saying like just do you want
to go to war are we gonna call this
video we're kissing all right so we're
gonna go to Huntington have lunch there
and get some work done I love that place
it's like it rising like this stuff it's
just so like natural answer all right
no but I want the real Huntington
Library now Huntington Library
we've changed I had to change out of
that shirt that I was wearing cuz there
was just a whole bunch of hair stuck in
and I was poking me but as I was trying
to figure out what to wear I realized
like my whole wardrobe
needs to kind of change with this hair
changed too because I was wearing some
shirts I like covered in my chest and
then it ended up looking a little weird
or like if I was trying to impair up the
clothing that I usually wear like a
certain outfit it just didn't look right
with the short hair so I'm like oh man
I'm gonna have to change the way I dress
myself now with this new look less hair
bow problems actually yeah cuz I pity my
hair in a ponytail just to see how short
it was and it was so funny the hair tie
itself couldn't even grab on to my hair
yeah we're gonna be eating first and
then we'll explore this is Casey second
time now cuz the first time he came we
weren't vlogging it but it was really
like the streets outdoors these days
nobody does I don't yeah really cool
good here that was so relaxing I loved
it so much I remember growing up when I
was little with my stepdads family we
would go to the park often and we would
lay out a blanket on the grass and that
was just like really pleasant memories
and so when I was doing it here I'm like
oh yeah remember that now and then it
just it felt really nostalgic really
nice this place is surprisingly really
good at with their food last time we had
the Chinese food now we have rikiya
sandwiches
okay that's surprising good ear you
don't think a library would have a good
food but they do this is more of like a
Botanical Garden kind of place like it's
kind of like an amusement park almost
it's like a resort almost feel a chip
even though these are my chips was the
one I was gonna you're gonna get this
one oh those are good when it bubbles up
like that but it's a heart yeah oh yeah
I know nothing but cheeks or cleavage
now you have it we can share it half a
heart you should this is the funnest
part if you bite it into it right now
and you get the poppies extra I got this
I got a I wanted to share half my heart
with you
[Music]
I'm so loving this hair I just love it
it just looks like one of those moments
where you hear about the hall no I'm
gonna tell you every time I play with my
hair you know the song that keeps
playing in my head it feels good it
feels good think you know yeah I know
he's hired like there's no songs in the
Middle's those an awkward like pile in
tips just beat
[Music]
and the modes their haircut - the bangs
beautiful deadly like your wife and
there's a beer anyway is it like your
walkie yeah there is a bee pollinating
how cute do your job little guy there's
another one over you save our world no
one there don't attack you okay let's go
oh my goodness
let's go don't bother me all I'm working
[Music]
you know it's funny when I was a kid my
mom cut my hair super short like a boy
short obviously shorter than this but I
remember I had friends I would have
these like bowl cuts I guess everyone
thinking like oh how lame like I
wouldn't want that hairstyle
ever and then now that I have it I'm
feeling like the greatest self of myself
ever if that makes sense what if I got a
bowl cut no please don't
Yuriy style isn't really nice where it
looks like that word yeah well cut it's
like a straight just all the way around
an actual like oh yeah Vic - they don't
thin out the bowl which she worked a lot
on me dating you know hanging out the
end so it wouldn't be so heavy I had a
bowl cut you did how are you I think
between second grade to 4th grade was
for three years straight I had a bowl
cut how did you feel then it was a style
then you're like I'm cool yeah the cool
kid and then that's great I got spikes
mouth things in and sixth grader had
spikes how do you remember your
hairstyle
I don't remember my aesthetic that's as
a good boy in school like that's like
your identity are you I identify with
the haircut ahead yeah I guess since you
don't have like girly stuff like
accessories or yeah I mean it's not
growing makeup or the jingle pants that
we had I could be identified by jingo
pants you know tink okay yeah I feel old
oh this is revered showing last time
each other why again is our hangout spot
in Hawaii we're going to Hawaii
we're leaving Arizona goodbye Arizona
what's up Hawaii
nice let's go lay down on the floor
that's the biggest canvas ever now we
can actually laid down because last time
we brought a blanket that's the sugar I
think he's always they never miss I miss
a little I think little Isaac yeah
five-year-old Isaac such a big kid now
I'm taking that man this is so comfy
where you got there some wine that we
vine we've got at the cafe where we had
lunch mm-hmm
maybe that's why we might be acting a
little suffering because we kind of got
but thank you during lunch a little bit
you don't get buzzed we get lovey dovey
cheers to the one cup that we have I was
like a deer Cheers
this is cool I never had a picnic styled
wine yeah thank you
yeah pinky yep I recently discovered the
joys of breathing cuz my whole life I
always hated reading every time I'd open
the book and I just start reading the
first chapter or like even the first
paragraph I would already start feeling
like I was gonna fall asleep and so I'd
be non-stop yawning I could never finish
a book and the only books I've ever read
were because I had to because of school
and so just let me borrow this book cuz
Gio gave it to her for Christmas and it
was really eye-opening now I'm gonna be
reading this book que onda gladly so now
I'm gonna be reading this book called
fully present it's about mindfulness and
meditation being fully here fully
present like actually experiencing life
and not living on autopilot mode so far
already learned a lot I can't wait to
finish this book and then just keep
reading books if you guys have any book
suggestions for me leave them in the
comments I'm definitely gonna be looking
forward to your book suggestions I
really like nonfiction kind of books
yeah just let me know I'm gonna start
reading now so after the library Casey
and I thought home Casey went out to go
pick up Isaac and Isaac doesn't know
about my haircut so we're gonna go see
his reaction I think
close your eyes turn around open your
eyes what do you think of my hair cool
you're like a puppy yeah
[Music]